this is the first session of the
foundations of Finance to me finance is
at the heart of almost everything that
you do in a business among the old
saying it's about the money
sounds crass but in business that is
always true because no matter what
aspect of business you're talking about
strategy marketing human relations
public relations it's still always about
the money that is how I think about
finance when I teach my corporate
finance class and when I teach my
valuation class in fact I'm often asked
what's the difference between the two
classes and there's actually a very
simple way of describing what the
difference is between corporate finance
and valuation in corporate finance you
look at a business from the inside out
you're looking at financial decision
making within a business how do you run
a business well and how do you create
value in the business in valuation
you're looking at the same business from
the outside in so with the driving
notion that it's always about money what
I'd like to talk about in this session
are six melding blocks that you need no
matter what finance class you take now
this is my subjective judgement there
might be others who believe there are
other building blocks but these are the
six building blocks that to me make up
finance the first is finances are very
simple and at the same time very complex
way of looking at businesses so I'm
going to start off with the concept and
structure of a business at least as we
see it in finance and in the process
we're going to lay out the philosophical
foundation for finance which is it's
always forward-looking it's not about
what you've done in the past but what I
expect you to do in the future that
drives the way we think about decision
making
the second big concept we're going to
talk about is cash flows finance is all
about cash flows as a bust as opposed to
what as opposed to accounting earning
some book value of assets
it's always about cash flows
understanding what drives cash flows why
they're different from earnings the
different types of cash flows is central
to understanding finance the third is
the notion the driving force of risk
everything in finance it's better on
measuring risk and making sure you are
all ready to return that is sufficient
given the risk you've taken on so in the
process we've got to define risk we've
got to come up with measures of risk and
we've got to come up with perspectives
andris sound strange but I'll talk about
that in a moment
the fourth big idea on which finance is
based is the time value of money
you all heard the saying right a dollar
today is worth more than a dollar you're
from now but why understanding the
intuition of time values centered also
understanding why currencies matter and
why the time value of money itself might
shift across time the fifth big building
block for finance is understanding the
basics of value how do you value a cash
a set of cash flows what are those cash
flows are contractually set what if
their residual cash flows what did they
contingent cash flows understanding the
basics of valuation and finally while
financial markets might not be necessary
to run businesses near the lubricants
that allow businesses to run well
understanding trading is central to
finance in fact every trade and likes to
make money without taking any risk and
in fact you'd like to invest no money
take no risk and make money that's
called arbitrage understanding what
makes arbitrage so difficult in markets
is again central to thinking about
finance so let's take a step in each in
in the right direction on each of these
six concepts let's start with the
concept of a business you've seen
finance an accounting balance sheet
right you've got assets you got
libraries a financial balance sheet lays
out the core of how we think about
businesses in a financial balance sheet
you want to see assets and liabilities
just like you do in an accounting
balance sheet but unlike an accounting
balance sheet in a financial balance
sheet when we think about assets we
think about not what you've already put
into these assets what are you invested
in them but what we expect you to make
from these assets in the future it's
always about the future and that's going
to change your perspective and what you
see on the asset side of the balance
sheet on the library of side of the
balance sheet I like to believe that in
finance we keep it simple
simple in what sense they're only two
ways you could raise money for a
business one is you can borrow the money
that's dead the other is you can use
their own money that's equity as you
expand as a business the layers of debt
inequity might change but they still
remain there still remain only two ways
you can fund a business debt inequity
the second big idea in finance is cash
flows we make a big deal about cash
flows in finance and it's it's useful
it's a critical that you understand why
cash flows can be different from
earnings because often the raw
information we have on companies takes a
form of accounting information
accounting earnings understanding white
cash flows and earnings are different
it's important to understanding why some
businesses that look good in an
accounting basis might not be worth very
much and others that don't look good on
an accounting basis could be worth a lot
the second big idea in cash flows that
I'd like to get through is that cash
flows can take one of three forms they
can be contractually said at the time
you're entering agreement that's what
you get with the corporate bond the bank
loan they can be residual cash flows
which is what you get when you're the
owner of a business or an equity
investor or they can be contingent cash
flows what a contingent cash flows the
cash flow will happen if something else
happens if an event occurs understanding
those different cash flows is useful in
valuing those cash flows then comes the
concept of risk we are as human beings
risk of us say that all the time but
what does that mean understanding how we
came to that conclusion or that we are
risk averse is central to starting to
think about risk and to convert that
risk aversion into our decision-making
we need to do two things one is we need
to understand that risk is not a bad
thing risk is not something to avoid
because to become a great business you
often have to seek up dress but you have
to seek out the right kind of risk risk
is a two-sided beast it's got good a
good side and a bad side and you want to
make sure the trade-off works in your
favor
the second big idea we're going to
promote is that when you think about
risk in an A
in an investment you got to look you
could ask the question risk through
whose eyes think about a publicly traded
company you've got thousands of
shareholders you got managers each of
them might have a very different
perspective on the risk in a decision
whose risk should dominate and thirdly
we've got to convert that risk
perspective into a risk number something
we can bring in explicitly into
decision-making you could actually argue
that the history of the development risk
measures closely parallels that
development of finance as a discipline
the fourth big idea is the time value of
money if you've taken a finance class
you undoubtedly have a financial
calculator take a look at that
calculator take a look at all those
buttons and take a look at that PB
button and look at how worn out it is
it's amazing how much of Finance it's a
present value problem in fact every
finance class starts with that Nostrum
and dollar today is worth more than $1
year from now but why understanding the
intuition behind why a dollar today is
worth more than a dollar year from now
is central to finance and converting
that intuition into mechanics in other
words if I get to give you a series of
cash flows can you bring them back to
today or can you move them forward to a
different point in time that's a skill
that anybody who claims me in finance
has to have which brings us to valuation
we'll have an entire class on valuation
but I'm going to start off by saying
something that I truly believe valuation
is simple if you keep it simple we
choose to make it complex in fact I'm
gonna argue that to understand valuation
you got to go back and think about those
three kinds of cash flows I'd talked
about because the way we approach
valuation is actually different
depending on the type of cash flow for
contracts reset cash flows the way we do
valuation is we use the promised cash
flows and we discount them back at a
default risk adjusted this country
that's how we value bond the promised
cash flows are the coupons in the face
value the default risk adjusted cost of
debt is what we used to discover them
for residual cash flows we estimate the
residual cash flows those expected cash
flows
we discovered them back at a risk that
reflects a risk we as investors see when
we invest in those residual cash flows
that's how we value equity for
contingent cash flows we need a
different token we use option pricing
we'll talk about the basics of option
pricing but if we can get those three
concepts down we can value just about
anything
and finally there's trading as I said
financial markets of the lubricant that
allow businesses to operate so
understanding the notion of buying and
selling the notion of training is
critical to understanding finance so
let's start off with every traders dream
every traders dream is to find something
to risk free and make more than the risk
free reign or put differently to be able
to invest no money take no risk and walk
away with profits that's a pure money
machine that's called arbitrage in
practice it's almost impossible to find
our Batoche if it exists it it's there
it's transient it's there then it's gone
so we're going to talk about the
frictions in the market place that
caused it to disappear why is it so
difficult for Chouard things to exist in
markets and we're going to talk about
two big frictions so first is trading
costs nice thing that's easy
it says the $4.95 I have to pay when I
trade not so fast
trading costs are much deeper they
include other items that we don't even
think about when we trade so
understanding those trading costs are
central to understanding why free
lunches are so difficult in trading the
other is taxes you've all heard the old
saying right there only two things in
life that I guaranteed death and taxes
and I'm not even sure about death taxes
are an issue in investing they have to
be an issue because as investors when we
invest in companies we get to spend off
to tax cash flows so bringing in taxes
into decision making into trading into
investing is central so let's lay the
foundations for how taxes enter into the
process those are the foundations on
which we're going to build these
corporate finance and valuation
buildings so let's make sure we get
these foundations right